hello everyone how are you guys doing
hope you guys are having a wonderful day
and as you guys can see by my gear I am
I'm a noob account which means today we
are here with a money-making method for
lower levels so I'm excited to bring
that to you guys you guys I had a lot of
support in the last video actually I've
just you guys wanting to see more of
these so it's something I'll definitely
do they won't be the most money per hour
however I'll do what I can to try to
make them at least you know efficient
gp2 xp kind of thing or a pretty decent
money making method this one's purely
money-making there will be no skill
requirements which is great you will
need a cash stack the more you have the
better typically how it goes personally
I was doing this in my newb with the
mill series with like two to three mill
like you can do with a lot less the more
you have the more you can buy over the
night overnight the more you can do but
this is one thing that uh you know I
found pretty decent I do have my best
money making guide
I have literally the best money making
method in the game that I have yet to
post to this channel which I know would
blow up and it's just so good that I
don't want to release it but I might
start a like I don't know how long the
episode would be it'd probably be for a
few months of me making that money in my
main and trying to build my bank back
with that method so if you guys want to
see that make sure you tell me about it
down below and like the video but let's
go ahead and get on into it so I'm gonna
head on over my GE and we're gonna see
what I got in store for you guys today
so let me kinda know I wasn't pressing
ctrl there we go so in the bank what do
we got we have a bank pin alright so now
that we are here we're gonna go ahead
and look at the bird's nest so I bought
six hundred and sixty two of them for as
you guys can see five point five K each
now this did take a little while but I
didn't change my offer after I put it in
so I got under cut the [__] out of and
so I haven't been able to buy anymore
since last night but I had those all
last night was hoping more would buy
overnight but they didn't because I
didn't have the updated price I'd
recommend before if you guys like go to
sleep or leave the house or do whatever
you check what the updated price is and
then just go with that don't undercut on
these things cuz people that do these
things are just sitting there
undercutting each other anyways you
don't be a part of that it gets pretty
cutthroat and the margins go [__] so
wouldn't recommend that I'm gonna board
this offer though and we're gonna go
ahead and buy
what a bird's nest is for so if you guys
there are crushed birds nests so if you
guys don't know what I'm doing right now
is I'm going to be crushing these birds
nests and kind of showing you guys how
much money you can expect to make so
that's not a really good margin what the
hell oh god last night as you guys can
see I was I was getting a 200 GP margin
so I'm going to go ahead and check out
GE tracker see what I can expect to
actually sell these on for and whatnot
and then we'll come back to it so give
me a second alright so I'm gonna go
ahead and take you guys over to GE
tracker they respond to remind if you
guys want to check them out they'll be
in the description down below they have
a lot of merging tools and stuff like
that so you can check them out but I
didn't anticipate on doing this but
since the margins aren't good right now
I'm gonna have to show you guys that
there are legitimate margins on these
things just so you guys don't think I'm
full of [__] and making this up alright
so I'm gonna go ahead and go over and
Here I am on GE tracker so this may not
be the most blown up but as long as you
guys get the idea of where I'm coming
from so these are regular Birds and
that's over the last couple weeks we'll
take a few days an example as of this
little stretch here where they had a
pretty consistent price of about 5.6 K
for about what looks to be about two
days in total now if we go over to crush
bird nest as you guys can see it's 5.8 -
the range of about five point seven
before they start to drop so
realistically they held around a 200 GP
margin then we'll also check something
along these lines from 5000 all the way
up to five point six thousand we're
gonna go ahead and check over there now
so that is four I guess you could get
them for four point eight all the way up
to five point two at which point it was
five point six over here so just kind of
showing you guys that there are
legitimate margins on these as you guys
can see I kind of bought mine at a bad
time since they're starting to crash
right now so that's why I'm not getting
the best of margins I bought these
overnight and waited to do them till now
obviously the best way of going about
doing this would be buying and doing
them as soon as you get them personally
I couldn't do that last night because my
roommate was in the room and he was
trying to sleep and I couldn't make a
video why he's trying to sleep alright
so if we go back over to the account
this is going to be where it's a lot
more in-depth or I mean this is going to
be where the real calculations come into
play I'm gonna calculate this at about a
200 GPM
as you guys saw that is a thing that
holds true for pretty much every day as
long as the prices aren't significantly
high or jumping or anything they hold
true to around 200 GP now after this
video they may drop and it may be kind
of hard to do since sometimes if there's
too many people bought into buying and
insistently it could actually come in as
a loss but over time it'll be better I
promise you that so I'm gonna go ahead
calculate how money you can do an hour
and then we'll see how much money this
could be per hour alright so the best
way to go about doing this would be to
go ahead and put the birds nests in the
bottom right of your bank just right
down here if you guys have mouse keys go
ahead and use those I will be using that
personally if you guys don't know how to
use them look up a guide on YouTube
since it's a it's way too hard to
explain in a video take out a pestle and
mortar and only have one in your bank
then make sure to go ahead and search up
your pestle and mortar if you have
placeholders down like I do and disable
the placeholder from there you're going
to want to go and fill Bank so once your
bank is fill there you go so you want to
make sure you have a slot for birds
nests and crush birds nests so what that
allows you to do is just not that that's
not what it allows you to do make sure
you take out his item what it allows you
to do is if you go ahead and say you
crush a couple birds nests that's just
what I'm doing right now and then bank
it won't bank your pestle and mortar
when you bank all and then you can just
go there and yeah it's pretty quick
banking that's the way I like to go
about it personally I put the pestle
mortar in the bottom right of my
inventory since whenever you crush one
it just starts from up here and it
doesn't start from like say that one
doesn't get crushed so that's the way I
like to go about it
I guess these things crush automatically
if you want to do this some more of an
afk way however if you guys see here
it's definitely a lot faster just to
crush them like this so I will be doing
that personally and we'll see how much
money we can expect to make per hour
alright so a lot of clicking later and
here we are so i crushing I crushed a
few for an example but I ended up
crushing around 640 nests in a total of
seven minutes not too bad if you ask me
I feel like that's that's pretty average
there is a way to do Mouse gouge six six
Jesus there is a way to do mouse keys
with this but I just don't have the
mouse keys for it and I'm not used to
doing it so this is just the way I
decided to do it if you know
use mouse keys for it go ahead and do
that yourself but as I was saying
earlier from what you guys saw as far as
migrate exchange goes once I go over to
history I'm only going to be making a
hundred GP off all of this which means I
made 66k in seven minutes which isn't
terrible which actually comes out to 560
K an hour which isn't too bad but the
problem with that is that that's not
realistically what you should expect at
the time that you see this video
realistically the margins will probably
never go lower than about 70 each so
even if this goes down like 450k it's
still viable the reason I would say that
it wouldn't go that low is because the
markets very easily changed on these
things from what I've noticed prices
fluctuate pretty quickly and not a whole
lot of people are going to want to you
know take the chance of risking a loss
but realistically there's the same odds
that it goes up and down depending on if
anything's you know going out in the
game if herblore supplies are in need
then these things will go up if they're
not need for some reason then they'll go
down I guess but it should be 50/50 so
with that being said and about a 200 GP
margin you'd be making around 1.1
million our 150 GP margin you'd be
making around 850 K an hour so you could
expect anywhere from around 570 K to
around about 1.1 million making money
these things will sell they are
herb-lore supply that I believe for
saradomin brew so you know that they're
going to sell so hopefully this video is
helpful for you guys if you guys enjoyed
it make sure to leave a like if you guys
have anything you want to tell me
comment about it down below I do
understand that you know this is a
low-level money making method but it
does require money but realistically a
lot of low level money making methods
that I'm going to try to show you guys
will require money because if I show you
guys ones that don't require money at
all they're gonna be pretty low and it's
going to be more so along the lines of
like white very collecting and stuff
like that I don't know why berries I
actually hold a pretty decent GP now
that I think they are know to drop from
places but something along those lines
you guys get what I'm saying is it would
be pretty simple and I don't think I
should go ahead and make a guide about
it but I can if you guys want that so
yeah make sure head up the
Twitter in the description and join my
clan chat and PM being game do whatever
you want of stuff and helpers is the
name nonetheless hope you guys have a
wonderful day and time still these bad
boys
[Music]